hitzerekorde werden in deutschland
aufgestellt wir diese große hitze über
steht hier die fünf besten tipps die
euch helfen sollen die sommertage gesund
und entspannt zu überstehen welche das
sind jetzt in kriegs und science fiction
auf facebook hatten wir diesen tipp
schon bei klick zum facts and fiction
den letzten nächten wird es euch viel
schwerer gefallen sein das einschlafen
durchschlafen ausschlafen und man kann
sich leicht erkälten ich kann ein lied
davon singen es ist einfach zu warm
es gibt aber einfache kniffe um bei
diesen temperaturen besser schlafen zu
können fangen wir mal an
bei der schlacht vorbereitung morgens
fenster auf aber nur solange es draußen
kühler ist sobald es wärmer wird fenster
zu und jalousien runter
vor dem schlafengehen solltet ihr einer
jetzt aufpassen lauwarme dusche nehmen
die poren erweitern sich durch das warme
wasser mit erweiterten poren kann sich
der körper schneller und leichter
abkühlen und wenn es warm ist unbedingt
zu decken also trotzdem zu decken am
besten mit einer baumwoll decke die ist
saugfähig und sie lässt euch nicht im
schweiß baden eine decke schützt euch
zudem noch vor einer erkältung über
nacht der körper kühlt nachts nämlich
viel schneller aus hilfe von down under
in australien haben die menschen oft mit
enormer hitze zu kämpfen und gerade
deshalb können wir uns von den dort
lebenden menschen ein paar tipps abholen
eine regel aus reihe ist beispielsweise
die slips flops lab regel slip steht für
leichte und luftige kleidung die man
sich ganz einfach überstreifen kann in
enger kleidung kann der körper
schlechter atmen und die luft kann
darunter nahezu überhaupt nicht
zirkulieren flop ging etwas wie wenn man
joghurt auf sei müßig tropfen lässt es
ist aber nicht gemeint sondern vielmehr
das verwenden von sonnencreme besonders
nicht wichtig dabei ist dass man darauf
achtet welchen sonnenschutzfaktor die
creme hat uns lab naja es ist eine
kopfbedeckung damit gemeint und also
immer irgendwas auf den kopf tun der
kopf ist eine der empfindlichsten
stellen am ganzen körper und diese
gehört geschützt bei so großer hitze
sonst fällt man auf grund eines
hitzschlags um also wer slips swaps lab
einhält sollte besser besser durch die
heißen tage kommen
ab zur kühltruhe dass kälte gegen gc ist
ja nicht gerade verwunderlich beim
einschlafen kann ein bisschen kälte
schon so einiges bewirken besonders gut
helfen dabei beispielsweise kühle decken
oder ein kühler schlafanzug dafür
einfach die genannten denn sie liehen in
eine plastiktüte packen und ab ins
gefrierfach damit vor dem schlafen
schnappt ihr euch diese dann einfach
wieder und können schon mal kühl in die
nacht staaten denen das dann immer noch
zu warm ist der kann sich eine
wärmflasche mit eiskaltem wasser
auffüllen und dann zwischen seine
oberschenkel legen warum zwischen die
oberschenkel dort wird das gekühlte blut
direkt und gleichmäßig im ganzen körper
verteilt
die us army rät wenn es zu einem
hitzschlag oder kollaps kommt wissen
viele außenstehende oft nicht wie sie
den betroffenen helfen können die us
army hat dafür ihre soldaten sozusagen
eine bedienungsanleitung dazu verfasst
erster schritt person in den schatten
oder in ein auto oder gebäude mit
klimaanlage tragen da die soldaten oft
in einer dicken uniform mit ausrüstung
stecken soll dieses sofort entfernt
werden und durch kühle nasse jacken oder
tücher ersetzt werden pro jahr fallen
bei der us army über 15.000 soldaten
aufgrund von hitze problemen aus damit
die soldaten robuster werden rät die
armee dazu schon vorbeugend zu handeln
ruhiges training an den heißen orten um
den körper an die temperaturen zu
gewöhnen viel trinken und auf warnungen
des eigenen körpers achten wenn die
soldaten damit einen wüsten einsatz
überstehen sollten wir mit den tipps der
armee auf jeden fall besser über die
sommertage kommen achtung lebensgefahr
eine gefährliche folge der hitze ist
beispielsweise die sogenannte wasser
vergiftung hypothermie so heißt die
vergiftung mit dem etwas merkwürdigen
deutschen begriff an heißen tagen
verlieren wir menschen nämlich jede
menge wasser das ist nichts neues aber
mit dem wasser verlieren wir auch
natrium salz und das ist gefährlich wenn
der natrium spiegel im körper nämlich zu
niedrig ist kann es zur hypo natrium
kommen erbrechen appetitlosigkeit und
kopfschmerzen sind die folgen und was
dann notarzt rufen und kein wasser
trinken denn das bedeutet dass der
natrium spiegel weiter fällt jeder
fehler kann dann der letzte gewesen sein
dieses horror-szenario könnt ihr euch
aber ersparen einfach viel natrium
haltiges also salzhaltiges wasser
mineralwasser das zum teil natrium drin
oder salziges essen zu sich nehmen eine
prise salz mehr zum essen senkt das
risiko von hypo krimi ansonsten lieber
nicht zu viel salz die hitze wird
übrigens auch eine große rolle wenn es
um das thema erderwärmung
beziehungsweise artensterben geht das
kann nämlich auch für uns gefährlich
werden und mehr dazu erfahrt ihr im
video hierzu rap und zum blog da geht es
hier und verratet uns doch mal in den
kommentaren welche tipps habt ihr wie
seid ihr am besten über die heißen tage
gekommen vielleicht wird das forum her
oder die kommentare unter dem video so
ein bisher eine tauschbörse für die
besten witze tipps also bis dann bleibt
dran